Federal senior living and hospice we
make sure your final years are active
dignified and pretty much permanent with
a staff of over 2 million spread across
hundreds of agencies you're free to
abdicate all of your constitutional
responsibilities to highly incentivized
lobbyists career bureaucrats and college
interns our members enjoy perks that
your constituents can only dream of
including voting privileges countless
opportunities for graft and nepotism and
an annual taxpayer-funded allowance of
more than a million dollars per year
take advantage of our luxurious on-site
amenities like restaurants pools gyms
members only elevators and substantially
weakened insider trading restrictions or
maybe you just like to relax and unwind
away from constituents microphones and
the uncomfortable truth surrounding your
voting record and declining cognitive
abilities Federal senior living and
hospice we Value Independence
wait that can't be right is that oh okay
yep that makes sense
wait does it